not too long ago saudi arabia was a
desolate wasteland filled with tribes
who were fighting for survival the area
had extremely low economic activity and
aside from mecca they had nothing going
for them on march 3rd 1938 however all
of this would change when the americans
found the world's largest petroleum
reserves in saudi arabia over the next
few decades much of the profits from the
area went to the americans while saudi
arabia was left with measly dividends
but saudi arabia slowly saved up these
dividends and started buying up these
oil companies that were drilling across
their country and eventually by 1980 the
saudi government would grow their stake
to a hundred percent which made them the
owners of the most profitable company in
the world saudi aramco saudi aramco has
since revolutionized the area into a
modern desert oasis but while their
cities are more modern than even western
cities they still have one fatal
bottleneck 92 percent of their budget
comes from oil now most of us have been
led to believe that saudi arabia has
enough oil to run for several decades if
not over a century but many experts
disagree because there's evidence that
saudi arabia may have been lying about
their oil reserves all along so how much
time does saudi arabia actually have it
before they run out of oil
to figure out how much time in saudi
arabia has left we can approach the
problem in two different ways which are
the supply approach and the demand
approach for this video we're mainly
going to focus on the supply saudi
arabia is estimated to have 260 billion
barrels of oil left and over the past 10
years saudi arabia has on average pumped
out roughly 10 million barrels of oil
per day this means that over an entire
year saudi arabia pumps out
approximately 3.65 billion barrels of
oil doing some simple math we'd find out
that if saudi arabia maintains their
current output they'd run out of oil in
71.2 years or sometime in the mid-2090s
this might sound like a long time away
but the thing to keep in mind is that
it's already been 84 years since saudi
arabia started pulling in oil revenue
this means that saudi arabia is already
over halfway through their oil roller
coaster but things may be a lot worse
than just this you see a lot of experts
think that saudi arabia has been lying
about their oil reserves all of the oil
reserve estimates that we've gotten for
decades now is from saudi arabia
themselves and the data is rather
sketchy first of all in 1989 saudi
arabia's oil reserves just randomly
skyrocketed from 170 billion to 260
billion but all of saudi's biggest oil
fields were discovered between 1936 and
1970
and no comparable discoveries have been
made in the last 50 years so how did
their reserves apparently jump by 90
billion barrels overnight something else
to note is that the timing of this jump
was also super sketchy while saudi
arabia took control of aramco in 1980 it
wasn't until 1988 that the americans
were fully pushed out and saudi
leadership was established and somehow
just one year after this change in
leadership through oil reserves
skyrocketed by 50
now that's definitely quite suspicious
also saudi arabia has been claiming that
their oil reserves haven't changed in 33
years this doesn't seem all that likely
given how much oil they've pumped out in
the past 33 years going back to the
saudi oil output graph we can see that
saudi arabia has averaged about 8.5
million barrels of oil over the past
three decades this works out to a total
output of 102 billion barrels of oil
also if we look more closely at the
saudis reserve data we'll see that they
have not only been claiming that their
oil reserves have stayed constant but
they've actually been claiming that
they've been increasing in 1998 there
were 258 billion barrels of oil but as
of 2016 there were 266 billion barrels
of oil
this means that saudi arabia was now
only able to pump out 102 billion
barrels of oil over the last 30 years
but they were also able to come out on
top by 80 billion barrels in other words
saudi arabia has been able to find 110
billion barrels of oil since the
americans left and that's in addition to
the initial 90 billion barrel jump so
apparently saudi arabia has found a
total of 200 billion barrels of oil
since they took over keep in mind this
figure is 30 billion barrels more than
what the americans estimated saudi
arabia had in total in the 1980s now i
know a lot of people aren't exactly fans
of americans but one thing i think we
can all agree about is that americans
are phenomenal at capitalistic
exploitation so the idea that the
americans exploited saudi arabia for 50
years and didn't even find half of their
oil reserves aka 200 billion barrels
seems pretty far-fetched to me but i'll
let you be the judge of that
it's not just the reserve data that's
pointing to inconsistencies either there
have been some major leaks over the
years that have pointed towards the
saudis lying in 2011 for example we saw
a leak from wikileaks that claimed to
cover insider info from a high-level
saudi oil executive according to the
executive over the years saudi arabia
had been overstating their oil reserves
by as much as 300 billion barrels also
something else to note is that saudi
arabia has never been able to pump up
production that much if they truly found
another 200 billion barrels you would
think that they have plenty of new oil
fields to drill from it and increase
production yet they have been unable to
top what the americans got them to you
see 10 million barrels per day is
nothing new in fact the americans were
able to reach this level with saudi
arabia way back in 1980 when they
reached 9.9 million barrels per day it's
been 42 years since then but the saudis
have barely been able to reach 10.7
million barrels per day
also it doesn't seem like the saudis are
holding back either for example even
when donald trump threatened to withdraw
military support saudi arabia couldn't
increase production to over 10.5 million
barrels per day
now you could say that saudi arabia
refused to respond to threats but they
weren't able to increase production even
when they were the ones that were
issuing the threat for example remember
when oil prices crashed between 2014 and
2016 oil prices crashed from 120 to just
42
and one of the main reasons for this was
saudi arabia you see the us was making
strides when it came to extracting oil
from oil shells this meant that the us
would become less dependent on the
middle east for oil so saudi arabia and
opec decided to launch a price war
against shale oil extractors the idea
was to pump up oil production and crash
oil prices to run these extractors out
of business this would have been the
perfect time for saudi arabia to pump up
production to 15 or even 20 million
barrels per day but they weren't even
able to cross 11 million barrels the
same thing can be said about the price
war with russia at the beginning of the
pandemic as well clearly saudi arabia
can't even surpass the ceiling that the
americans got them to which just makes
it even more likely that they've been
lying about reserves but all of this
brings up the question why lie wouldn't
it be better for saudi arabia if
everyone knew that oil reserves weren't
as plentiful less supply equals higher
prices which means more profit for saudi
arabia right well this would be true at
the beginning but it wouldn't last long
you see even with saudi arabia's likely
inflated figures they don't actually
hold the world's largest oil reserve
this title actually goes to venezuela
who holds 300 billion barrels now
venezuela oil has never been that
helpful to the world because the country
has been plagued with corruption
hyperinflation and who knows what else
but the second the world knows for sure
that saudi arabia doesn't have as much
as they said they're going to turn their
entire focus onto the remaining
countries we'll see historic strides in
venezuela and canada heck we might even
see the western world make amends with
russia
at the same time the push for renewable
energy will also become stronger than
ever before and all of this will reduce
the world's dependency on saudi arabia
and given that oil is the only thing
that gives saudi arabia any sort of
significance on the world economic stage
this would not be in saudi arabia's best
interest for them it's best to keep the
rest of the world as dependent as
possible on their oil and if that means
lying about their oil reserves then so
be it
if saudi arabia has been lying about the
reserves this entire time how much time
do we actually have until they run out
well if we assume that the last accurate
piece of data we have is from 1988 when
the americans left this means that saudi
arabia was left with 170 billion barrels
of oil
realistically it's possible that they've
increased its amount by 10 to 20 percent
over the past 34 years so we'll give
them the benefit of the doubt and call
it 200 billion barrels at eight and a
half million barrels per day on average
saudi arabia would have used up 105
billion barrels since 1988 this would
leave them with a 95 billion barrels
left today if saudi arabia continues to
average eight to 10 million barrels per
day this would mean that they only have
roughly 25 to 30 years left if saudi
arabia has been lying it then i think
this is likely a pretty realistic
estimate now we could of course go full
tin full heart mode and become doomsday
theorizers what if saudi arabia founded
no new oil after the americans left and
what if 20 of the remaining 170 billion
barrels was unusable this would mean
that saudi arabia only had 136 billion
barrels of usable oil in 1988 given that
we've used approximately 105 billion
over the past 34 years this would leave
them with just 31 billion barrels a day
at this rate they'd be out in less than
10 years while that sounds scary it's
more than likely not true while saudi
arabia may be lying about having 70 to
100 years worth of oil left it's likely
that they at least have a few decades
left and this matches up with the
kingdom's actions as well if they truly
had several decades worth of oil left i
don't think they'd be going all in on
growing other source of revenue over the
past couple of years saudi arabia has
made insane strides when it comes to
adopting western standards women's
rights and human rights in general have
gotten significantly better and they've
even opened up their country to tourism
for the first time they've also been
pouring billions of dollars into
airports and tourist attractions so it
seems like they're pretty determined to
turn their country into a tourist hub
just like dubai there's also the whole
vision 2030 project led by muhammad bin
salman which aims to significantly
reduce the country's dependence on oil
if such projects go well i think it's
pretty realistic for saudi arabia to
become independent from oil by the time
they run dry so while they may be
tricking the entire world regarding the
reserves they're not tricking themselves
and they're very much getting prepared
for a future without oil
while we can argue that lying about
their reserves is unethical and
manipulative from an objective
perspective they've actually played
their cards really well by overstating
their reserves they've been able to
maintain their dominance within the oil
industry their crude oil exports are
literally twice as high as second to
place this has allowed them to build up
a war chest that's worth nearly half a
trillion dollars they also took saudi
aramco public a few years ago at a 2
trillion evaluation so it looks like
they're slowly wanting to cash out over
there as well
in the meantime they've also started to
aggressively diversify their income
streams so it looks like saudi arabia is
poised to do extremely well even after
they run out of oil as for the rest of
us we may not have as much oil left as
we originally thought but maybe that's a
good thing maybe this is exactly what we
need to finally make the jump to
renewable forms of energy and deliver
gas guzzling days in the past but that's
just what i think do you think saudi
arabia's all reserves are sketch comment
that down below
also drop a like if you're excited for a
renewable future and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
to subscribe and see more questions that
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one